Dr. These are my financial disclosures. So, as we heard a few minutes ago, so,
loncoxtrexamab/tesirine is an antibody drug conjugate consisting of CD19-directed monoclonal
antibody in combination with PBD dimer, which is an active drug, which is what causes majority of
the anti-lymphoma activities. So, this is a LOTIS 5 trial design. This was a phase 3 confirmatory
trial for loncoxtrexamab/tesirine. The study involved a non-randomized safety running phase
in which 20 patients were enrolled. Patients received loncoxtrexamab/tesirine 0.15 milligram
per kilogram in combination with rituximab every three weeks for the first two cycles.
Subsequently, the dose of loncoxtrexamab/tesirine was reduced to 0.075 milligram per kilogram with
rituximab every three weeks. Total number of cycles were offered were eight for all patients.
After the safety running, patients were randomized to, in one-to-one fashion,
to loncoxtrexamab with rituximab for a total of eight cycles versus R-Gemox for a total of eight
cycles. The primary endpoint is progression-free survival by independent central review.
The key exclusion criteria include patients with relapsed diffuse-dot B-cell lymphoma after one
prior line of therapies and those with measurable disease. Patients should not be a candidate for
stem cell transplant based on performance status, advanced age, or any other significant
comorbidities per the investigation descriptions. So, for the safety running, 20 patients were
enrolled, and this data represents the safety running period. The randomization results are
awaiting. So, out of 20 patients, majority, almost half of the patients had advanced DLBCL.
The majority of the patients has relapsed disease.
As you can see, out of 20 patients, median number of loncoxtrexamab and rituximab cycles
were administered were five. One-third of patients only could finish all the eight cycles of treatment
and 20 percent of patients withdrew from treatment due to adverse events.
Now, in terms of side effect or safety profile, grade three treatment emergent adverse events were
reported in 55 percent of patients. Serious adverse events were reported in approximately
half of the patients. And 40 percent of patients were reported in 55 percent of patients. And 40
percent of patients had steady drug withdrawal due to treatment emergent adverse events.
Now, in terms of efficacy results among 20 patients, overall response rates were 80 percent
and complete response rate was 50 percent. Just to give the perspective,
single-agent loncoxtrexamab in LOTUS2 had a CR rate of 24 percent and response rates were 50
percent. So, this was significantly higher than what we have observed in third-line settings.
Now, in terms of side effect, grade four treatment emergent adverse events were reported in 55 percent
of patients. Median duration of response was eight months. And for among patients who achieved CR and
MRD negative, there were 50 percent of patients and half of the patients had MRD negative at the
end of treatment. These were the biomarker results. On the left side of this slide shows essentially
CD19 scoring pattern and the best overall response. Essentially, it shows that the response rates,
as you can see, were 40 percent higher than what we have observed. So, this shows that the response
rates, as you can see, were 50 percent higher than what we have observed. And this shows that the
response rates, as you can see, were 50 percent higher than what we have observed. And the best
overall response rates, as you can see, were 50 percent higher than what we have observed. And the
best overall response rates, as you can see, were 50 percent higher than what we have observed. And
the best overall response rates, as you can see, were 50 percent higher than what we have observed.
And the best overall response rates, as you can see, were 50 percent higher than what we have observed.
So, in conclusion, this trial shows that fixed duration, fixed treatment duration of long-coxytuximab
rituximab showed no new safety signals and it has promising activity. We are, however, awaiting
the randomization studies for definitive results. Now, moving on to the LOTYS7,
which was essentially a combination of long-coxytuximab to serine with the glofitamab.
This study started out with the 3+3 design. Long-coxytuximab was tested in
90, 120, and 150 micrograms per kilogram. And then the study was moved on to the phase 2 portion
in the dose expansion arm, where long-coxytuximab was tested in 120 or 150 micrograms per kilogram
in combination of glofitamab. This was also finite duration treatment. Long-coxytuximab was given for
8 cycles and glofitamab was given for 12 cycles. During cycle 1 day 1, obinutuzumab pre-treatment
was given cycle 1 day 2. Long-coxytuximab was given and glofitamab was started on day 8 of cycle 1.
And subsequently, both long-coxytuximab and glofitamab were given every 3 weeks.
This is the study population. Total of 49 patients were enrolled. The median age was 70 years in
both groups. Majority of patients had de novo DLBCL. Half of the patients had germinal center cell of
origin. And 16% of patients had double and triple hit as a subtype of DLBCL lymphoma. Median prior
line subtherapies were 1. And prior CAR-T cell therapy was in 16% of patients. And primary
refractory disease was present in half of the patients. In general, this is a busy table,
but essentially, grade 3, 4 treatment-related adverse events,
the event rate was 80%. And grade 5 or serious adverse event rate was also similar to what we
normally observe with long-coxytuximab. The point of showing this table is essentially the combination
of long-coxytuximab and glofitamab did not have any additive toxicity. And the side effects were
pretty much what we expect from the single agents. Now, in terms of cytokine release syndrome, you can
see here the CRS rate was considerably lower, almost half in patients who received 150 microgram
per kilogram compared to 120 microgram per kilogram. Majority of the CRS were limited to
grade 1 and 2. Only one patient developed grade 3 CRS. ICANS rate was also quite low. Only two
patients in the 120 microgram per kilogram developed ICANS. There were no ICANS in the
higher dose of long-coxytuximab . Based on this data, the 150 microgram
per kilogram dose is being moved forward for more patient enrollment. The dose discontinuation
of both long-coxytuximab, tesirine, and glofitamab was also extremely low, around 6% or so.
Now, the efficacy data is something I want to highlight here. The overall response rates are
90%, quite high in both groups. And the complete response rate are approximately 78%.
In relapsed DL-BCL setting, these complete response rates are considered quite promising.
And the median time to CR and time to response was approximately six weeks. That's when the
first scans were performed. So, in conclusion, long-coxytuximab and glofitamab has demonstrated
promising activity with an overall response rate of 81.9% and complete response rate of 77%
in relapsed large B-cell lymphoma. CRS of all grades was 25% as selected 150 microgram per
kilogram dose and 52% at 120 microgram per kilogram dose. And ICANS rates was 4.1% across
dose levels and all were grade one and two. Thank you so much.